Про "блакитні шоломи" на Донбасі
Володимир Путін заявив на саміті БРІКС у Китаї
На його думку, наявність миротворців пішла б на користь
розв’язанню проблеми на Сході України
При цьому пролунали і застереження
Може йтися лише про функцію гарантування безпеки
співробітників ОБСЄ. Перше
Друге - ці сили мають перебувати на лінії розмежування
і ні на жодних інших територіях
Пізніше стало відомо і про російський проект резолюції ООН
Місія має тривати щонайменше півроку
За пропозицією Москви
військові ООН повинні мати лише легку зброю
а пропозиції щодо величини та складу майбутньої місії
представить генсек ООН Антоніу Гутерріш
Тим часом у Німеччині сприйняли заяву російського президента
з обережним оптимізмом
Так, для очільника МЗС Зіґмара Ґабріеля це стало
цитата – неочікуваним сигналом
Рішення Москви, на його думку, могло б стати першим кроком до скасування санкцій
Втім, набагато важливіше те
що з пропозицією про введення "блакитних шоломів" в Україну
Росія демонструє зміну у своїй політиці, яку нам ніяк не можна втрачати
Нам потрібна Росія для вирішення конфлікту в Північній Кореї
Нам слід було б сприйняти це як привід до початку дискусії
про розрядку та в цілому про східноєвропейську політику Німеччини та Європи
Зіґмар Ґабріель також відзначив той факт
що Росія у минулому відкидала введення миротворчої місії ООН на Схід України
Нині ж оглядачі вказують на рух Москви у правильному напрямку
хоча і висловлюють серйозний скепсис щодо цього
Тим часом Україна розробила свій проект резолюції
в якому сказано, що Росія не може брати участь у миротворчій місії
а "блакитні шоломи" мають бути розміщені по всій зоні конфлікту
включно з українсько-російським кордоном
Київ не має наміру узгоджувати розміщення миротворців
з представниками самопроголошених республік
В німецькому уряді – схожої думки
Сферою дії такої місії має бути весь регіон конфлікту
на Сході України, а не лише контактна лінія
Загроза спостерігачам ОБСЄ з боку сепаратистів є не лише поблизу неї
але особливо неподалік українсько-російського кордону
Крім того, офіційний Берлін, як і Київ
категорично проти участі сепаратистів в ухваленні рішення
про місію ООН на території України
Це було б неприйнятним підвищенням значимості
самопроголошеного керівництва так званих "народних республік"
Також з’явилася реакція і німецького МЗС
Там заявили, що не зацікавлені у замороженні конфлікту
як це було, приміром, в Грузії та Придністров’ї
Мета ж усього процесу - якомога швидше виконати Мінські домовленості
Втім, оглядачі зазначають, що "блакитні шоломи" ООН
це не ті люди, які можуть вирішити конфлікт на Сході України
Миротворці, передусім, згідно зі статутом ООН
гарантують безпеку, політичну підтримку та сприяння миру в країнах
які вже виходять з конфліктної ситуації
Причому керуються в ООН трьома принципами
згода сторін, неупередженість, незастосування сили
за винятком випадків самооборони і захисту мандата